is there a reliable way to measure the
durability of one's natural immunity
is there a reliable way to measure the
durability well here's the problem so
there's two ways that you can interpret
that question which is um you know do
you have immunity at the moment from
having been exposed to code past
um and there are various questions about
whether or not you know circulating
antibodies and such are
a good measure um but the other the more
the potentially more interesting
question uh is is there any way to know
you know a month out from having had
covered whether or not your immunity
will um you know persist forever as
it seems often to do or if
um or not and i don't i don't think we
have an answer to that at all i i don't
think we have a perfect answer but i
think we have a kind of way in first of
all i would say okay antibodies are
certain to be a terrible measure
right that this is we have been sold the
idea that antibodies are the end-all and
be-all of immunity by people who just so
happen to be in the business of selling
crappy vaccines that generate a
temporary boost in antibodies so anyway
that's a sales pitch and we should get
over it
the best immunity comes from t cells
which have something antibody like on
their surface but you can't just go in
and measure the t cells in the same way
that you can measure the circulating
antibodies
so antibodies do we have a good measure
no that's the problem is that actually
it's a tricky question so
we can measure antibodies easily and so
we choose to measure it's a it's a
tyranny of metrics thing right
antibodies are easy to measure but they
also as a function of a healthy response
to a pathogen with which you have been
infected will drop precipitously after
that infection right
because if your immunity has
been housed over in t cell land where it
is best
then the point is those antibodies you
know there's some optimal level and it's
not a high number so you expect antibody
levels to drop
so anyway the point is what you want to
know
is is your durable immunity there and
how permanent is it which is going to be
a function of a couple things one how
good is the memory on the immune system
side and two how rapidly changing is the
pathogen so that the memory is actually
useful
right so the evolution of a pathogen can
cause a you know robust immune response
to be irrelevant because by the time you
get your next encounter it doesn't look
the same
so
what you want to know
is
across a population we should probably
assume something like a normal
distribution or maybe it's a power law
that would describe
how long people's immunity lasts right
and so if the immunity is not going to
be very long lasting for a given
pathogen and its interaction with the
immune system then you would expect some
people
to get readily reinfected right people
who are on the low end of that
distribution they should be very
vulnerable to a second infection
to the extent that you have
few documented cases of anybody getting
a second
infection then that suggests it's likely
to be very long-lived because that tail
of the distribution is all are also very
well protected so that's not a perfect
proxy but that's how i would look at it
complex systems wise well i mean there's
also the question of how distantly
related is the virus that you are now
exposed to from the virus that you have
immunity to
so if you know if omicron is so
different from delta
that
you know the anecdotal reports that we
hear of people who were sick last summer
and then again sick a month ago
are true
um that you know that is consistent with
actually you won't get delta again
but right um but omicron might you know
put forth a new form um that you could
be susceptible to because it's different
enough from the one that you now have
natural immunity to yeah i mean i think
that's a different way of saying the
same thing about the rate of evolution
of the
pathogen the basic point is
immunity depends on similarity
between
right the thing that you became immune
to and the thing that you encounter and
a rate of change that is sufficient will
outstrip that at some point
[Music]